what up it's your boy or mean Pentagon
family catch me on the bootleg cat
podcast yes sir
bootleg cat podcast man special guest in
here my guy my man
wait is my chair too high is it going
down slowly there it is here
what's up bro thank you for having me
yes sir new album is out it's out mean
yes which means what mean is really what
everybody calls me obviously right I'm
saying it's very autobiographical but I
also figured it'll be an acronym you
know manifest everything avoid
negativity really because I like
manifested this project you know what
I'm saying first of all it's produced by
Scott Storage all of it all of it um
well to be technical there's two songs
on there that Scott Storage didn't do
but he oversaw the whole process there's
15 songs two bonus tracks and then 13
records with the last two is not Scott
shout out my boy pyro who did that but
yeah it's basically produced by Scott
Storage
um I work with him the first time it was
like I want to say 2017 or something
would you say like one joint right you
know through Steve Lobel and stuff shout
out to Steve and um I was like man he
might be the one you know I was looking
for that like that production
and I left that session like yo this guy
I don't know how I can get him to do a
whole album because he ain't cheap you
know what I'm saying but I'm like yo
this is the guy for me you know what I'm
saying I feel like he has that balance
obviously he's a go producer long story
short it happened you know I mean like a
year and a half two years later
we kind of reconnected through like my
new partners and everything and um they
had a great relationship and they kind
of reintroduced me to Scott like yo
let's not just sell us a beat like this
is really our guy you know I mean in our
community The Armenian and they're like
yo this is really our guy we got his
back and like let's work
and one thing led to another we did the
whole project do you have to pay for all
the Beats not well no one works for free
right you know what I'm saying so but
it's like we gave him a few love we gave
him a fee and just like less work you
know what I'm saying so you didn't you
got you got the the homie rate the super
homey rate super homey because yeah
Scott Storage beats ain't cheap yeah man
that's my dog thank you Scott I
appreciate it yeah but yeah he he also
got excited though once we started
working he's like oh okay like you know
I'm saying we started really having
records once I finished like the French
joint he was like bro you have a smash
on your hand then I brought NOS to the
studio he's like hold on NAS coming to
the studio right you know what I'm
saying so once we started working he
started seeing like what I'm doing and
you know what I mean how I'm putting
everything together and he started
respecting it more and more yeah because
on the album you got Nas you got quavo
you got offset right
uh it's a ridiculous tracklist I got Nas
quavo offset YG
uh Method Man kabaka pyramid shout out
to myth hell yeah shout out to meth that
was the easiest one there's just one dm
and two weeks later it was in my in my
inbox he always showed me love but I
didn't you know I wasn't sure that's
crazy yeah
uh Jeremiah and French
you put the LeBron record on this bonus
yeah yeah the two the two bonus tracks
is King James with Jeremiah and then
yeah French I call it bonus because I
mean they were made during that process
but we had already dropped them right
right right right right so you know I've
kind of put them as bonus but that King
James joint is still my highest stream
it don't stop you know I feel like it I
feel like it's it was it's like a sync
record for like the playoffs and [__]
yeah last last year uh ESPN synced it
yeah he was playing it during the games
you know it's always like a time limit
they they they license it for like three
months is that like the
best way to make money off the actual
song outside of streaming is that I've
had some good money off like
um the ESPN one was cool to be honest
but like commercials yeah you can get
your [__] in a commercial that like
plays on a lot yeah um a few Netflix
like TV shows and stuff I've had too in
the past yeah that that not only like
the money they pay but um it just brings
awareness you know right like people's
gonna find it online that [__] pops up
on one of your most streamed songs
because people
Shazam it and [__] you know what I mean
have you ever done any ghost riding for
anybody
uh no nah not really would you ever do
it yeah people need help written songs
um
yeah I feel like local people but I
don't really but not really you know
right right not not like super like yeah
you know yeah I kind of haven't really
focused on that I feel like it's been
mentioned to me multiple times you know
what I'm saying so yeah that might be a
thing to look into especially for these
a lot of these rappers need help with
the verses man it's just weird though if
you like a mcmc then usually I'm sure
people do but it's kind of weird if it's
not weird anymore yeah I don't know I
guess I'm from that cloth where like you
could write a song for like coil array
yeah of course but that wouldn't be like
bars
yeah shout out to coil already yeah I
never met her she's not a fan yeah she's
she's fired she posted a great photo on
on the gram today did she yeah she had
the uh my guy she had the uh yeah
I'm surprised we'll go check it out
Community guidelines yank that thing
down I'm surprised uh anyway
um yo so the um our Armenian uh genocide
anniversary date was recently right
recently it's on April 24th uh every
year you know I always been super
involved in that right I'm saying like
you know every Armenian kind of grew up
learning about this about how it's not
recognized and you know anything
unrecognized you basically give people
the right to do it again so his three
repeats type of thing you know what I'm
saying so this is something that you
know we all in our households have been
really
taught so from early on I was at
protests and things like that you know
and then when I started rapping I'm like
yo I was kind of you know the first
Armenian the really rap I literally was
the first um now there's obviously more
people but no one yet at this level but
I was like yo I got to tell the story of
my people you know so I did a song
called open wounds and then you know we
printed these shirts that said our
wounds are still open and I wore it in
the video yeah it was actually the 10
year anniversary this year for that of
that shirt of the the whole thing got a
video to shirt that's crazy because I
see those shirts everywhere everywhere
so if you're like in Glendale or Burbank
you see those shirts and the stickers
and all that everywhere yeah man it
became really um I mean someone one time
told me it's like the biggest logo in
our community like there's one like coat
of arms type thing that's like a
national Armenian thing you know that
everybody gets tatted and the second one
is that our wounds are still alive it's
crazy that was an honor but for me it
was really a way to kind of like
encourage
first of all the youth of my own
Community to like you know I mean keep
that that Spirit Alive and care about
[__] like that basically but also
obviously spread the message to like
people like yourself and other you know
I mean other races to know about our
history so that's just really hip-hop to
me you know I mean question familiar
people you see a
the most famous Armenian like Kim
Kardashian become single right
do you like
you try to you know bring her over back
home you know I mean
I mean if I could get in the room
I wouldn't mind you know what I'm saying
because I just saw a clip somewhere of
like I think it was her mom was like
trying to like who could find her that's
like an old uh I know it's old it's all
like a keeping up with a Kardashian yeah
yeah yeah yeah her mom was trying to
hook him up with my boys the Platinum
brothers or one of them you know okay
okay Motorsports because they do all
their cars they Bend for like mad years
shout out to George and Jack so yeah
there was a there was an episode with
Chris I don't know if that was real it
was for the show but it was hilarious
every time I see it I don't know if Kim
was interested at the time but that [__]
was funny I think you should give it a
shot man I think she's I mean she's
single you know yeah you just shoot her
a DM just be like hey shooter only has
200 million followers she should dm with
you know the Armenian flag and be like
hey I'm a fan yeah I'm sure I'm the only
one that's gonna do that let me take it
get some good food in Glendale
where would you I would say you would
take her to rafi's I mean
she's obviously Armenian but I don't
know if she's super tapped into the
Armenian Armenian like restaurants and
culture I don't know maybe she is so
you're saying that be the restaurant so
I would probably you know I'd be giving
rafi's way too much love like every time
I've never gotten a discount but every
time someone asks me I bring up raffies
you know and I post that's what
everybody always says rafi's is amazing
I was there the other day um Carousel is
another one both in Glendale
yeah I haven't really thought about
where I would take him
did you start thinking we got to
Manifest this man on this manifest we've
been manifesting [__] lately so the Kim
K you be you guys would you guys would
literally own Armenia we would bro you
can could go with own Army she's like I
already own Army yeah
I don't need you I'm a billionaire leave
me here yeah yeah that's crazy
um what's up y'all bootleg Kev here man
got to tell you about our new sponsors
at King Palm baby got a shout out to
them and we're welcoming them into the
new family man of course uh we treat all
of our partners at the boole cat podcast
like family shout out to King Palm man
if y'all don't know about King Palm they
are the leaders in the smoking industry
when it comes to their tobacco-free
blunt wraps no nicotine no tobacco just
good old leaves all right yeah that's
right um and look their product that I
love are these right here now these
right here are the pre-rolled tips you
just stuff them with your your herb your
cannabai that you get from a Hardin and
uh
they got these terpene and flu infused
uh tips now what they are is you put
your wheat in there all right you hit
the [__] little pinch on that thing
and you could just burst the flavor now
these are the red reins which is like an
energy drink flavor obviously they got
the Strawberry Shortcake which is also
gas now this is what's dope too there's
just so many lines of these rolls uh
shout out to the leaf tubes you can get
these blueberry these big blue grape
Fusion joints so much you can get man so
many products uh check out your local
7-Eleven your local smoke shop all that
but you could also go to kingpom.com
right now and get everything online
delivered right to your door for half
off 50 off if you use that promo code
bootleg that's right shout out to King
Palm man we're talking about essential
smoking uh when it comes to like just
getting that Clean Smoke it's not too
harsh or organic you ain't putting
nothing crazy in your lungs you know
what I'm saying shout out to King pong
no tobacco no nicotine just straight
look and I gotta shout them out too
because
can we take just take a a good look at
this
you know we got multiple sized King Palm
hitters over here
I think right there is like a goddamn
Jesus
that's a [__] boy right there you
know what I mean shout out to King Palm
that's a king pong Leaf right there
stuff with some fire some fire all right
so look right now you're going to want
to go to uh kingpom.com uh use that
promo code bootleg get half off whatever
you need smoking accessories Leafs some
of these awesome uh pre-rolls that they
have that you just stuff your stuff in
stuff your stuff in you know what I mean
um kingpom.com 7-Eleven your local smoke
shop all that make sure you follow them
online at King Palm and check them out
speaking of stuff that you're stuffing
shout out to my bookie man my bookie you
already know mybookie.ag I'm riding with
the Phoenix Suns God damn it them Sons
going all the way uh if you are like me
and you like to uh you know put a
friendly wager on some sports
which I do a lot I've been using my
bookie for about 10 years now uh you can
go do the same thing right now now this
is what's dope about my book you go to
mybookie.ag it's the online sports book
not only is it an online sports book
they got the Blackjack they got the
whole Casino situation craps roulette
whatever you're into you could play it
right at mybookie.ag and if you use the
promo code bootleg when you sign up
bootleg you'll see it down below
[Music]
when you sign up you'll get that first
deposit bonus now get a new account
mybookie.ag when you sign up bootleg is
the promo code first deposit bonus up to
a thousand dollars you put in money they
give you money it's that simple all
right there's so many ways you can win
money of course they got NHL right now
the playoffs are happening in hockey if
you're from [__] Canada and you care
about a terrible boring sport also
basketball NBA playoffs are booming
right now put all the money on the
future for the sunset with a
championship thank me later I got Suns
versus Celtics in the uh finals also
baseball
another atrociously boring sport but a
great sport to gamble on all right so
what you're going to want to do go to
mybookie.ag use that promo code bootleg
right now and get uh your first deposit
bonus unlocked speaking of unlocked
unlock your [__]
go to bluetooth.com right now
it is summertime if you're dealing with
elect erectile dysfunction Ed if you
will maybe you got stress at work
maybe you're tired of looking at the
same chick maybe you just need a little
pep in your step
um you need to get on that blue too man
you don't need to do anything but it'd
be nice to have the option to so go to
bluetooth.com right now
use the promo code bootleg and get the
first month supply of Bluetooth for free
what is Bluetooth
well Bluetooth is a chewable gets
delivered to your door in a discrete
package no doctor's appointments no
doctor's visits and uh it has the same
active ingredient as Viagra
and Cialis
so we're talking about getting your dick
hard here in case that one over your
head you know it won't go over your head
once you take it I promise you that all
right Bluetooth also is uh incredible
because not only does it come in the
blue chewable flavor with the same
active ingredient as vibrancy house but
it also has a mint chewable flavor which
is the same active ingredient as Levitra
all right all this if you're questioning
I don't know I don't want to spend no
money on does this [__] work look yes it
works and you don't have to spend money
if you use the promo code bootleg
at bluetooth.com because it's going to
get delivered right to your house
they're going to give you a month's
supply for free you just got to pay five
dollars shipping that's it the
bluetooth's come into your house no
awkward doctor's appointments no awkward
doctor's visits it's all online
bluetooth.com thank me later thank me
later let's get back to the interview
what was like for you outside of Nas
you've done some big records with you've
done records with some [__] Legends
like what what what uh
is the record that almost happened
or that you thought Mike could still
happen in the future that you haven't
worked with somebody in terms of just
like an artist because I know we had
discussed in the past you would almost
did something with Eminem back in the
day yeah but today that's crazy
um the probably the craziest almost
story was nipsy
um
because I had just started working with
Scott I didn't have literally none of
these features yet right we just start
cooking up and my partners you know
that's from the Cannabis game he just
randomly brought up like you know I'm
mad cool with Nipsey and the team and
this is when Victory lat was everywhere
and they've seen my favorite rapper like
especially then right that album like I
was like yo Nipsey to one and um
he's he called him right on the spot you
know what I'm saying and he's like you
know we work in this and this and that
let me introduce you to my guy you know
so briefly introduced us we started
slowly building that relationship never
met in person yet right and then he
connected me one of his team members I
send the record over and he hit me back
saying yo nip [__] with it you know
he's down to do it
um I'm like yo if it's possible I'm
trying to be in the studio all these
features except meth and French all the
others we're in the studio in the studio
together you know what I'm saying crazy
it's a different energy bro like I feel
like the Nas record would have been
wouldn't have been that if it wasn't if
you guys weren't vibing with each other
on the hook together and [__] like that
so you know if I can which nowadays
obviously not easy especially for like a
big artist like that but anyway I asked
him and he's like yeah no problem imma
hit you you know top of the week and we
set it up
and that Sunday he got he got killed bro
damn yeah crazy crazy story
um so yeah rest in peace rest in peace
besides that yeah I've been around a lot
of people and it's like
um you know me and Ross talked about
doing something at one point
you know I learned like you can't take
too long when these opportunities come
take off we talked about this in the
last interview it was a brief combo with
takeoffs like yo send me something
because I upset and I had cuevo
um
I'm like yo you're the only me go out
and do a record yet you know what I mean
he's like yo what we doing send me
something you know and I lagged on it
you know what I'm saying but it's not
just because I lagged it's like I felt
like I didn't have the right record yet
because I hate having mediocre records I
see this all the time with a big name
for sure if you click on it like it's
cool that doesn't do nothing for you you
know I mean for your career it's just a
waste of Smash If you have really
something undeniable and then you have a
big name on it it just helps then then
you got something you know what I'm
saying uh you have a this is a
one-of-one jacket you have on yes sir
thank you so when Jeff Hamilton when he
does so how much is this jacket
so basically uh this this Jag is kind of
a funny story Jeff Hamilton is my man
like I I got in a couple of jackets and
I got introduced to him to some mutual
friends and we became homies and then
one day I had a video shoot with be real
for a song called God flows
um and be real studio is literally maybe
a block or two away from Jeff Hamilton's
like showroom store or whatever so I hit
Jeff I'm like yo you think I can borrow
a jacket for the shoot he's like of
course come through so I go over there
and my boy found this one kind of
hanging in the corner it's like a
one-of-one custom you know I mean he's
like yeah I did that for a rapper
um I don't have to mention him but he's
like basically he ordered it but then he
never picked it up you know what I'm
saying ten thousand dollars but he's
like I don't care to me my jackets are
art you know I hang them up I don't give
discounts this and this and that so I'm
like cool he's like yeah take it for the
video I'm like perfect this is a perfect
Vibe for the b-real video this that I
went we shot the video on the way back
we go to drop it off my boys like the
whole time during the shoot my boy's
like yo this [__] is too fire like I
need jacket you know but I didn't think
he was serious right we went back to
Jeff Hamilton and he he went up to him
he's like yo I need to cop that jacket
you know what's my price he's like I
really don't give discounts he gave him
like a thousand bucks off so he paid
nine thousand cash on the spot I'm like
bro and then he's like well every you
were in the video already so now
everybody's gonna think I borrowed your
jacket
so technically this is not my jacket but
everyone's gonna think it's my jacket
you know 9 000 jacket Jesus Christ yeah
Jeff Hamilton is a beast dog right
everything he does like every time I
wear a Jeff Hamilton jacket you get
compliments by everyone that well yo Sig
jacket you know what I mean for your
time bro so I feel like I've known you
for so long but you were being so like
kind of there was like a period in time
where I felt like you were just like
holding on to everything in the last
couple years you just been letting [__]
fly you know what I'm saying are you
gonna continue not for sure are you
going to continue that same amount of
output yeah I kind of learned you know
two years ago we put the project out
with Berner and I wasn't really ready to
continue the buzz I got off that you
know what I'm saying uh I put the King
James Record out and then kind of like I
wasn't ready to keep up you know it's a
Content game now and like no matter how
good this [__] is you got to follow it
up right so this time I made sure to be
ready so this album is definitely like
my the one I've been like working on
but I'm like deep into the next one
already so yeah we're gonna keep going
do you fall 20 23 for sure I was gonna
ask you do you feel
um being an Armenian rapper is it that
much harder to kind of get through some
of the doors and get to get people to
kind of check you out
I think it definitely
um you know hip-hop is growing right and
it's becoming so much more universally
accepting right it's the biggest genre
exactly so slowly it's getting I guess
less and less but at the end of the day
we all know what the culture is you know
what I'm saying and we all know the
initial doors a lot of people are not
just down to support just anything you
know what I mean it's got to come for so
I definitely had some certain hurdles
you know what I mean and like or a lot
of time people are like yo you dope but
then turn the other way like you know do
your thing but it's never like let me
come [__] with you right I mean because
there's no real other connection I come
from a whole outside culture I you know
what I'm saying so I I feel like any
other race it has a positive and a
negative because it sets me apart you
know what I'm saying yeah then you got
your your people are [__] my people
[__] with me heavy um so you know and
nowadays it's all about building your
own independent like fan base anyway
more than anything uh but yeah for the
industry to kind of [__] with you and
it's not that easy what would be some
advice you would especially sorry to cut
you off like when I started because I've
been doing this decade plus now like
French Montana was just you know what I
mean or DJ Khaled or people that look
like me wasn't really around yet or they
just started so like it wasn't yeah it
wasn't the norm what's up guys hey um if
you are watching this
and it's April 20th 4 20.
I'm going to be hanging out at hardean
today
that's right put the flyer up The Rock
I'll be at hardean um hanging out all
day today
um the craziest most just luxurious
illest dispensary in the world located
right in Las Vegas Nevada now Hardy in
Las Vegas they are our family they'd
sponsor the podcast I love those guys
dearly and when I say that it is the
best place I've ever walked into to buy
premium cannabis I'm not lying best
customer service
best bud tenders best bud
put in your King Palm
and uh just overall man just a great
experience um so what y'all need to do
is go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas follow them on the
gram
we got a lot of dope stuff in the works
they actually just opened a a fire
podcast studio so we're gonna be doing a
lot of content in Vegas
live from Hardin they also just dropped
a [__] tennis shoe with Fila they got
dope fly gear
um man premium cannabis the best
selection
culture
sniff you walk in that man listen they
got I'm not even lying to y'all Harding
has their own signature scent and it
smells good I keep a bottle of it in my
car literally maybe twice a day I spray
get that hard eating whiff smells
amazing so look make sure you go to
hardine uh if you're in Vegas get in
that Uber get in that cab as soon as you
touch down say take me to hardine the
taxi drivers the Ubi drivers they know
exactly where it is because it's the
hottest spot in Vegas they go take you
straight there you're gonna tell them I
sent you they're going to get you
situated real nicely all right Harding
underscore Las Vegas go show them some
love go to hardinglasvegas.com gotta
give a shout out to our oh geez my dogs
had Odd Socks baby they've been [__]
with us from day one
um and they've been dropping so many
crazy dope new like socks you know first
of all can we talk about Beavis and
Butthead they just dropped the Beavis
and butt head socks and draws let's take
a check just a nice little peek at the
Beavis and Butthead oh
come on man
they also just dropped Coca-Cola we got
Scarface we got Reese's we got the big
[__] Lebowski so many dope socks the
most comfortable socks in the world the
most comfortable underwear in the world
and check this out right now you can get
20 off that's 20 off at checkout
at oddsoxofficial.com using the promo
code bootleg so go right now
oddsoxofficial.com my first uh
suggestion would be get you a pair or a
pack of the Odd Socks Basics the black
and the whites those are my go-to's and
then you gotta [__] with some of these
Big Lebowski socks
and they just got Coca-Cola
they got the Scarface boys like what are
we talking about man what are you
waiting on they are the most comfortable
socks in the world
um so if you're not wearing Odd Socks
you're just cheating yourself you know
what I mean you're really cheating
yourself
they got [__] South Park
come on bruh what are we talking about
go to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg save 20 off at
checkout on the most comfortable socks
in the world or don't and keep torturing
yourself with those shitty socks you're
wearing right now
be a damn shame anyway let's get back to
the interview yeah French is like
he's like as far as like people that
look like us like either one that really
did it you know what I'm saying it's
from Morocco right Morocco yeah which is
technically Africa but it's a middle
eastern kind of a culture and the looks
and everything you know what I mean so
what would be the advice you would give
uh because you've kind of like you said
you've been doing this for 10 years plus
and you kind of you know at the end of
the day you make mistakes you correct
you you're probably still learning as
you go but it won't be a stake in the
world what would be the advice you would
give like one or two things for an
independent artist that's just like
maybe in a rut that that you know they
can't figure out like do I drop music
there'd be maybe they're hesitating too
much maybe they're overthinking this
[__] what would what's something
overthinking and hesitating is not is
not the move but really what it is is
consistency so
once you feel like you know you found
your sound you find you know you're
you're lane or whatever now you just
gotta Stack Up on the music Stack Up on
the content and then just go and and
understand that it's going to take a lot
of groundwork you know what I'm saying a
lot of you know probably several years I
wouldn't Bank on just going viral maybe
that'll happen yeah it's like winning
the lottery you're right if we go buy a
lottery ticket right now what's the
chances right so that that happens to
one in a [__] hundred million maybe
but
um if you consistently put out quality
[__]
you know the fan base slowly grows you
know I mean and you grow your own that's
really the only way so anything you
learn from Berner because you you were
on the Rover burner you do a project I
mean you've been around them a lot yeah
burn is a beast man the way what I
learned from burner is just his output
is so incredible it's crazy he runs this
like massive [__] billion dollar
company yeah right and then he still
puts out multiple projects a year you
know what I mean and I see how he does
it and you know for every artist is
different but he he books the studio for
a week and that's all he focuses on and
he boom he drops done in a week boom and
then move on to the next thing he don't
have the time to sit there for a year or
for six months you know what I'm saying
so but yeah man really just the work
ethic that the consistency the output is
crazy you know was that there was some
man
he got some crazy ass fans too man I see
you know I went on tour with him one of
the dopest toys I've been on yeah you'll
be surprised every single show sold out
everyone's singing along to every song
and then the smoke is not normal even he
be backstage because I would go on right
before him so every night I would get
off he'd be like how bad is it today
like how bad is the smoke cause we be
rapping on up there live he's a big boy
it hits you like bro I can't breathe in
this [__] you know what I mean
like a super fire alarm box yeah fire
alarms went off every at least every
other show what about was it anything
different or um
any anything you you might have learned
from Chris Webby who you're also close
with also was on the road with who also
was an independent Juggernaut I would
say from I learned a lot from Chris Webb
because he was like one of the first
people I went on tour with
um the whole touring aspect the Show how
he put his show together you know what
I'm saying I started using one of his
drummers as my drummer then I started
using his DJ I'm like I started
realizing what I'm missing in my live
show that's not just all about me and I
can't just carry the whole [__] right
you know what I'm saying like if you
have the right DJ that's strong on the
mic that's helping you know I mean it's
almost like a hype man but not a hype
man then you know I mean like certain
elements and the way he does it bro is
like
again it's consistency he started this
thing with Webby Wednesdays oh dropping
hella records yeah yeah every Wednesday
he was but he was doing it the right way
right he was cooking for like three four
months and then the rest of the year he
would hit him every week at the end of
the year he would hit him with an album
same cycle for like five years he's been
doing that and I seen it grow like he's
getting hundreds of millions of streams
no he's killing me you know I mean every
every year and every show like I've been
on like three four tours with him
this shit's crazy shout out to Webbie my
brother great guy man yeah uh all right
so the album's out mean go run it up yes
crazy features intro's crazy yeah man
it's one of my favorite songs
um yeah the features are crazy but
honestly I'm just really proud of the
whole
the whole project like how it came
together I feel like Scott brought out
of me what I hadn't been able to show to
the world yet like I knew I had this
potential but I didn't have the right
you know I mean the right music the
right everything to really shine that's
what good production does I guess you
know what I'm saying so do you have any
Kim Kardashian stories for you
Scott not
I mean yeah he told he just told me that
they've been together a long time ago
but he wasn't really talking like greasy
or anything yeah he was with everyone
apparently everybody he was he literally
was with everyone he's Mr he's literally
I Hit It First he's the one yeah he's
the one that little yeah Kim is just one
of the names bro like yeah that's that
short little talented guy with those
glasses and all that weed Talon does a
lot yeah Talent does that boy starts on
them Keys every time I'm impressed like
every single time every decision like
Jesus Christ he did it again it's crazy
man you know what I mean like well go
run the album up it's out right now uh
we got a freestyle that's crazy you can
watch yeah and uh your new album is out
but you already got [__] in the tank but
right now me now right now produced by
Scott Storage thank you tour coming I'm
working on it but we're doing The Rock
Show with the Roxy if you're in L.A
Thursday Thursday May 4th uh definitely
pull up to that and uh we got your boy
Alexis
we hanging out man my bro appreciate you
thank you yes sir look fire